foreign
the hour being nine o'clock we will open
up our capital budget overview committee
agenda for those in attendance welcome
to Public Works
um I we have the minutes of the March
10th meeting that have been distributed
are there any corrections or emissions
that we need to address move to approve
as written and presented seconded
thank you motion made by Senator Lang
seconded by representative Boyd
um
any further discussion seeing none if
you're in favor of the motion signify by
saying aye aye
any opposed
motion passes unanimously
I would like to move to with no old
business I'd like to move to a new
business
Canon Mountain advisory commission item
number
23014 Department of Natural and cultural
resources and whom would speak to that
good morning ladies and gentlemen for
the record my name is John davivo I'm
the general manager at Cannon Mountain
ski area and Franconia Notch State Park
and I have an accomplice with me
uh good morning Chris Marino Chief
Administration for the Department of
Natural and cultural resources
so this is our proposed eight hundred
thousand dollar Capital plan for fiscal
24. this was recommended to commissioner
Sarah Stewart at dncr by the Canada
Mountain advisory commission concurred
by the commissioner comes before you for
review and approval and if so we would
then go to the governor and executive
Council in a meeting forthcoming if
approved there any contract would go
through back through the council and any
direct purchase would go through the
department of purchasing I can lay out
specifics or I can answer any specific
questions that you may have on a per
project basis if you could could you
just give me a USA Today overview please
sure
in general this year fiscal 24 will be
concentrating on uh lift maintenance
lift upgrades lift repairs I can detail
those and we'll be concentrating on snow
making improvements on the Hill from a
snow making perspective
we're looking at 550 000 to do three
particular projects those are all
primary routes and serve primary areas
of terrain that would be air hydrants
water hydrants Airlines and water lines
there's a fifty four thousand dollar
pump rebuild and replacement of
everything from the head down
and there's a thirty thousand dollar
item there for compressor upgrades which
allow us to better stage our air usage
and realize that efficiency probably in
one year on having to manufacture and
use less air in the system compressed
air is our primary cost with snow making
on the left side
there's an 81 000 item there for a
gearbox rebuild on The Cannonball quad
that's our primary lift at the summit
there's a fifty thousand dollar motor
rebuild item there for also The
Cannonball quad
um there's a twenty five thousand dollar
item there for bull wheel bearings for
the Peabody quad that's our main line
out of our primary base Lodge and
there's a ten thousand dollar item there
for upgrades to the middle double chair
which was installed in 2011. we want to
do a full-blown uh tear down and
reassessment of the electromechanicals
of that lift okay
questions for the gentleman
um yes represent void
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony just uh two lighthearted
questions number one how did the uh the
under eight under 18 championships in
the Eastern championships that's really
cool uh how is how to how we were able
to pull that off with the Yeah we
actually uh we had made probably 97 of
the amount of snow we were going to in
that area we got hit with a bunch of
snow in early March we hosted the u18
the under 18 national championships uh
had a couple hundred athletes from all
around the country scored rave reviews
on our venues we've got a world-class uh
giant slalom and Super G venue we've got
a world-class slalom venue there we had
also just hosted the Eastern High School
championships with 250 athletes from
Wisconsin down and over through Virginia
also scored rave reviews for that
congratulations thank you follow up Mr
Truman yes please again another
lighthearted question has um has the
bear Den been activated this year yeah
it's funny every time we have a meeting
at Peabody Lodge they're literally
roaming right through the the front yard
so to speak awesome yeah okay thank you
um Sandra Lang
um just I'm looking through your notes
from your last
um kind of mountain advisory commission
meeting and I was looking at your
scanned visits versus car counts is this
the first year you're doing that so uh
we're assuming that this year is
probably a more accurate number compared
to yes yeah thank you for asking so we
for 85 years believe it or not we had
essentially been on the what was the ski
New Hampshire model of every vehicle two
and a half people every bus is 50 people
every van is uh is 10 people you kind of
take a blended average uh where you you
balance out against your all tickets
issued times 1.36 to account for
Passover usage you've got an average
um
not surprisingly
the the scanned access stuff came in at
about 10 off of what we had always shown
as a typical uh and that's about what we
anticipated given where Revenue was
where natural snow was
where where visits were
um so yeah but at this point we've got a
Baseline and we can move forward from
that this is going to be the new normal
right we'll use this well hopefully the
enormous higher right and I would expect
I would suspect that it will be you know
we lost 15 days last year which is about
10 of our season
great thank you
thank you uh a couple of questions if I
could I spoke about your air compressor
and higher Efficiency do do we I guess
would be the question do we own most of
those or are those least like other
operations come in for Winston yeah no
we actually we own everything at this
point the uh the days of folks Leasing
air capacity uh have kind of Gone by the
wayside when I was at Attitash we did a
lot of that it you're better off owning
over the long term for sure okay and my
my other question I had a meeting with
commissioner Stewart just a couple days
ago uh speaking about uh amateur radio
repeaters uh on different sites and uh
and coming to a better policy for that
do either of you gentlemen have any
knowledge of I know that there's at
least one repeater in Cannon Mountain
do you see that that's a incompatibility
problem at your facility no I don't
think so we actually operate on three
different channels for Canon and
Franconia Notch State Park and I know
that uh the gal who had most recently
been in the Telecom and radio
communications
job at dncr had been dealing with three
or four different primary contractors
essentially to get them to provide
upgrades to our plant in order to have
space on that on that plant but that's
completely separate from our operation
we also host State Police
Fire EMS Etc yep no I appreciate that
I'm a believer that that operation is
our last line of defense and if there
were issues I wanted to hear about that
so
um any any further
a not and lighthearted question it's a
legitimate question okay please thank
you
um again thank you for taking the other
two questions the um based on reading
the reports uh excuse me the minutes
that you provided staffing has been a
challenge I guess my question is losing
the 15-day staffing issues the ski
school which I know drives a lot of
traffic
um how much has that impacted your
overtime budget
tremendously
that's what I want yeah we're pretty
heavy into
OT at this point uh we're working we're
crunching a lot of numbers and we're
going to do some stuff with payroll
we'll do some stuff with uh with perks
and Denny's and you know of course we
have a goal to hire more Folks at the
class 50 level and therefore cut on
overtime for sure and I guess the
follow-up if I could miss the job please
still still running still running even
budget wise credits versus our
anticipation is that we'll finish fiscal
23.
essentially dead even over the 85-year
Long Haul okay good deal moving a lot of
money around and as as we're allowed to
do thankfully right okay thank you Mr
chair Senator Lang move to approve cap
23-014 seconded motion made by Lang
seconded by Boyd any discussion
if you're in favor of the motion for
item number
I lost it 23 19 23 0-14 thank you
Senator uh signified by saying aye aye
those opposed
um item 23014
um is approved
um like to move to uh item 20 thank you
gentlemen uh item number 23013 peace
Development Authority uh division of
ports and harbors
request authorization to spend 81
975 dollars from the harbor dredging
appear maintenance fund
morning Geo thank you please introduce
yourself
good morning okay it's on
um good morning uh members of the
committee for the record Geno Marconi
I'm the director at the peas Development
Authority division of ports and harbors
uh in this request we have before you as
a result of the
storm we had back in December that uh
blew out the sea oil down at right Arbor
we're fortunate that
we have a contractor that does uh snow
plowing it's located right up the road
and he has all of the equipment and came
came down the morning after the storm
opened up the roadways so that the uh
the boaters the primarily the fishermen
that continue to operate during the
winter months had access to the docks so
they could get out to their boats and
then over the next few days they came in
and restood the wall again I brought in
some additional armor Stone
we had worked pretty closely with uh
Emergency Management and giving them our
estimates on what the costs were going
to be because they were putting in the
request for uh
to declare it a disaster and so we were
working working through that and then
when the presidential the classic
disaster notification came out what we
were trying to do was get the funds from
that but apparently I was told at
Rockingham County didn't qualify didn't
meet meet the threshold
so uh that's why we're here today to
request this money be released from that
fund so that we can pay the bill
thank you questions for director
thank you um
uh did you ever did you have a question
represent boy yes I did Mr chairman
thank you Gina thank you for your
testimony thank you for the pictures
um is there anything else that needs to
be done that that's not included in this
particular request that should be
brought to our attention or is this this
is what needs to be fixed well this
we're just paying for what's been fixed
I understand that I guess I'm looking
if I may Mr chairman um
it's an ongoing problem down there it's
just the Dynamics of the Waterfront uh
uh the year before we had a winter storm
and it blew up out of the wall down on
the on the north end of it uh where
route 1A comes across you know we put
that back together we beefed it up with
some additional armor Stone uh you know
that was a 42 45
000 fix there uh and it held up during
this storm so what what improvements we
did there we did those improvements here
on this section of the wall now uh it's
a dynamic place I mean the facility was
built back in 1960 and when they dredged
Dry Harbor and they put in the
reventment but the whole facility was
built on top of the marsh
so it's like it's like building your
house on top of a sponge yes that's a
good analogy thank you Mr chairman thank
you
um I hear Sandra with a motion
thank you Senator Waters uh moves to
approve uh seconded by Boyd any further
discussion
if you're in favor of
um project 23013 peace Development
Authority division of ports and harbors
you would signify by saying aye
aye those opposed uh passage unanimously
thank you director
what did you say you're welcome
and we will take up uh item
23010 Department of Transportation
request approvals for uh two million
eight hundred fifty five thousand two
hundred and ten dollars Turnpike toll
credits
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Andre Brier
Deputy Commissioner and hdot I've got
two of my colleagues with me today to
talk about these items in turn we had
two items that both deal with uh use of
Turnpike toll credits for the first item
uh I will let uh Bill Watson introduce
himself
um
good morning everyone for the record my
name is Bill Watson I'm the
administrator of the Bureau of planning
and Community Assistance at the
Department of Transportation
thank you would you just tell us real
briefly what the total credits are being
used for
so under RSA
um toll credits are are allowed to be
used automatically
for prior approval for roadway and
Bridge construction reconstruction one
of the areas of our federal funding that
we receive is in the area of planning
dollars
that are used both by the department by
Regional planning commissions that we
contract with through Governor Council
UNH and other other groups that we
contract with
to provide Statewide planning Regional
local planning efforts throughout the
state
um the existing statutes do not allow
for the automatic use of toll credits so
this request is essentially asking for
the use of toll credits to match the
anticipated Federal funding that we're
receiving over the next two years are
there questions for the gentleman yes
please
thank you Mr chair
um being new to the committee could you
just explain what toll credits are and
how they come about
certainly so
we have a lot of investment that is made
by the state on roadways that are
classified as federal aid eligible or
not federally eligible some of those
dollars estate dollars some of those
dollars of federal dollars
we have so our Turnpike system I-95 the
Spalding Turnpike the FD Everett
turnpike through Nashville and up
through Manchester are all classified as
federally eligible roadways
but we do not use federal dollars on
those roadways to maintain them we'll
use the toll revenues collected at the
at the toll booths to to maintain and
improve those roadways
so there is a calculation process that
we go through with Federal Highway
Administration on an annual basis to
calculate basically a three-year rolling
average of how much State investment
that we are making on those Federal
eligible roadways
when those Investments reach a certain a
certain threshold that's acceptable to
Federal Highway then we calculate the
value of that state dollar that's used
in those Federal eligible roadways and
those are allowed back to us from
Federal Highway Administration as toll
credits which essentially replace the 20
match that's required for most of the
federal dollars that we use
so it's a mechanism to allow the
department to fully utilize the federal
uh the federal funds that we receive
through the Federal Highway
Administration without the requirement
of using a 20 State match
thank you
I must say after all these years that
was a great explanation thank you that
could go a long time thank you I
appreciate that any other questions yes
uh Senator group 2310 seconded motion uh
motion by Lang second by Boyd to approve
2310 uh yes 2310 any further questions
if you're in favor of the motion signify
by saying aye
aye and opposed
motion passes unanimously gentlemen will
move right to 2311 requests to approve
use of 384
000 of toll credits
thank you Mr chairman uh I'll let my
colleague our director of Aviation Rail
and Transit Shelley Winters introduce
herself
because Deputy Commissioner said my name
is sheller Winters I'm the director of
Aeronautics Rail and Transit and happy
to answer any questions or give a brief
overview of the request before you
related to Federal Transit
Administration match of Turnpike toll
credits and if I'm this is a new
position for you then I've been
accustomed to seeing you here with
correct in the past I came before you as
the administrator of the Bureau of rail
and Transit congratulations and thank
you for that
um questions
yes yes Roger
disability to participate in the
National program would would be NTA be
benefiting from the funding here for
what they do providing services to
people in my community
thank you for the question so this this
uh is requested match for the Federal
Transit Administration 5310 program
which are funds that are available to
help seniors and individuals with
disabilities so the request before you
is to provide the match to fund eight
full-time Regional Mobility managers I
have a map that may be helpful to
contextualize where the eight regions
are
um and yes so Nashua Transit and
Manchester Transit Authority all the
public transit providers as well as
social service agencies are are part of
this Regional coordination effort to
help staff call centers to help find
agencies that provide transportation
services to help find funds within the
community Through philanthropic
organizations Community County funds
Municipal funds to help try to
centralize the delivery of volunteer
driver programs and demand responsive
programs aimed specifically at seniors
with and individuals with disabilities
so very likely your neighbor and the
Transit Agency in your community with
either directly or indirectly benefit
from this program
thank you Senator Lang so I just had a
question I'm looking at this I'm
thinking of our you know Lakes Region
area and a community action program does
a lot of this function about helping
with mobility and for seniors and and
disabled people how does this integrate
with that at all or is it completely
separate uh effort
so this requests if it moves forward one
of the positions in in that region the
community action program at belnet and
Merrimack counties they are the lead
agency through which These funds will go
to and will be going to governor and
Council later this year for a two-year
contract so that Agency for the the
greater Region Three again the map may
be helpful and I should hand that out um
we'll actually go to that agency so that
again we're building on the efforts that
are already out there and just trying to
coalesce them and bring them together so
not necessarily create new but Aggregate
and bring together and create
efficiencies within regions
any further questions
uh could I just ask that you leave us a
few of those Maps I would like to see
that I appreciative of the Senator's
question
um
Mr chairman move approval of 2311. uh
motion motion made by Boyd seconded by
by Sandy Lang to move item 23 to approve
23011 Department of Transportation
request for 384 thousand dollars of
Turnpike toll credits if you're in favor
of the motion you'll signify by saying
aye
aye those opposed
motion passes unanimously thank you Mr
thank you thank you three
um there are some informational items
included uh thank you for that uh in
your packet does anyone want to have any
uh discussion on those items
yes please
uh I was just a request to get it on the
record if Das could when they provide
spreadsheets as part of their
documentation they could actually
provide the underlying spreadsheet it
was suggested to me by LBA that the best
way to get that on the record was just
to request it now since they're not
actually here that'd be okay thank you
is is there someone here from Des on the
one stop
okay we'll uh we'll get more of an
explanation
yes
well let's
the um I I guess
I was somewhat confused by the
spreadsheet that was that was sent well
I didn't mean that especially it was
confusing what I'm asking for is the
actual spreadsheet the electronic
document the Excel spreadsheet oh okay I
think it's include that when they send
out the documentation it's easier for me
to read
happy to take that back and uh for
future submissions thank you very much
I just want to say that the just for
clarification uh the spreadsheet I
believe that representative is
discussing is the one that comes from
administrative services that provides
the status of the capital uh budget
projects
um Des that that's the one that has the
long Pages folded yep Des is here on the
one page document so if you have any
questions about the one page document
which is the one stop
okay
are there questions on the one page
document by DS
seeing none thank you appreciate you
coming uh any further discussion on the
items that were brought forward
um
Christopher Pam do you have a tentative
date for our next meeting
I apologize for the informality of first
names uh we did not come up with a date
um it could be at the call of the chair
if that's preferable
um
all right I mean I believe your
intention was probably not to meet
through the summer and come back
sometime in September that's correct I
need to check with Senator waters on his
summer schedule
they're seeing there's not a lot of
Summer down there okay so uh with that
I'll entertain a motion to adjourn
second uh moved by Boys second by Lang
uh we are adjourned and until the next
time
at the call of the chair thank you
we will begin in five minutes with the
next presentation which will be a long
range long-range Capital planning and
utilization committee we'll be in recess
for five minutes